hey guys it is for 24th of August my
name is Jess and you're watching gang
[ __ ] news yesterday I told you we'd be
getting dark souls 3 DLC info today and
here it is right on schedule bandai
namco have officially announced that the
ashes of arendelle expansion will come
to ps4 xbox one and pc on october 25
while the DLCs plot hasn't been
explicitly revealed players will
apparently be traveling to the frozen
land of arendelle to defeat the evil
within and uncover a terrible secret
bandai namco is said to expect new
weapon and armor sets new magic enemies
challenges and law which expands the
Dark Souls 3 storyline the DLC will cost
15 bucks on its own and is also included
in the $25 season pass you can check out
the full trailer for ashes of arendelle
in our story on gamespot no man's sky is
getting a brand new ps4 patch this week
our games has announced that the 1.06
patch will resolve ninety percent of the
games crashing issues the developer
added on Twitter we obviously won't stop
until these issues are one hundred
percent resolved also these patches
contain other fixes and improvements to
the studio also revealed that every time
the game crashes a report is sent to
hello games and they've been working
through these since launch several
patches have also been released for the
problematic pc version that addressed
seventy percent of the known issues with
another major update to be released
sometime this week hello games has
promised that once they've sold the
issues with no man's sky they will begin
to work on the promised additional
features such as base building and space
freighter ownership so you finally got
somewhere to put all that plutonium a
bunch of images and details have leaked
about the new DualShock 4 controller
that's arriving with the ps4 Slim's
Twitter use a short man 82 got his hands
on the new controller and has revealed
the new game pad features a bunch of
tweaks to the base design including a
new light bar right above the touchpad
and I know how much you will love the
light bar Y bar will show the same color
as the light on the back of the
controller oh yes to light bars
presumably this is so you can see light
notification
more easily short man 82 reported that
the controller uses the same battery as
the old one but it appears to have a
better battery life he added that it's
possible to force the controller to use
the wired connection if it's plugged
into the ps4 buy a USB which isn't
possible with the old controller head to
gain splatter four stories on civ 6 and
battlefield one and I will see you again
tomorrow